you faced some proper fears in the
making of
this film they made you go on a roller
coaster
well here's the ridiculous thing they is
me
i developed and produced this film so
you would think that i wouldn't have put
terrifying things out there like singing
on stage which is something i hate or
riding on roller coasters something that
i loathe
look at this oh god i was crying that
those are tears
um that sweet girl next to me the
beautiful actress jenna ortega
she had to sit next to me she said that
her fingers were almost wrenched off i
was holding her
squeezing her hand so hard most of the
take was not usable because i was
screaming
jenna her character's name was katy
i was cursing i was praying um it was a
very it was a big day for me i had to
have my big girl panties on this
yesterday sounds horrible